after one of the previous banking videos
I got a comment if everyone puts gold in
the banks what can they use to transact
or to buy food or to pay for services
etc and that is an excellent segue into
the notion of a banknote banknote you've
probably heard the word before maybe in
in some you know Charles Dickens novel
or any or something but we're going to
find out in this video this is actually
a much more familiar concept than you
ever realize and you probably have some
of these bank notes in your wallet as we
speak so let's go back to our example I
have the Bank of Sal I use 100 gold
pieces let's my equity let me draw that
my equity I have a hundred gold pieces
and I use that to build a building so
the hundred gold pieces actually go to
the builders and they're from out of
town so they're not going to deposit it
back with me so that's my building
if you can see that it's a little
picture of a building and then all of
the villagers in my city they come in
and deposit their golden because my
building it looks very solid and safe
safer than their mattresses so they then
deposit a thousand gold pieces with me a
thousand gold pieces so on the liability
side of my balance sheet I could say Oh
a thousand gold pieces Oh
thousand gold and then on my asset side
I actually get the gold pieces I should
have done that in yellow but so on my
asset side of the balance sheet which is
strangely tilting to the left on the
asset side I actually have the thousand
gold pieces thousand gold pieces so
there's actually sitting in my vaults
now the question was if if if all of the
villagers put all of their gold into my
vaults what can they use to transact
every day the way I drew it right now
these are mine let me do some decide is
my assets and these are my liabilities
right I owe them a thousand gold pieces
that they can come and get any
any moment and you know this could kind
of be viewed as a checking deposit well
alcohol go into that in a second I'll
probably go into that in the next video
but if all of their thousand gold pieces
are sitting right here on the asset side
of or at least in my fault what can they
use to transact well the solution is I
say hey you know instead of taking some
of your gold out and using that as
essentially money why don't I give you a
note a note that says you put X amount
of gold into my vault so for example for
each one gold piece you draw that for
each one gold piece I will issue a bank
note so let's say I'll say one gold
piece bank note outstanding bank note
outstanding I know you can't read that
but that says one gold piece bank note
outstanding and then I hand you a slip
of paper and that slip of paper and this
might start to look a little familiar to
you say it looks about this shape slip
of papers that shape it has a nice
picture of of Sal in the middle because
the Bank of Sal and it is denominated as
one gold piece one gold piece one gold
piece and now you gave me that gold
piece and you get this green piece of
paper that it's that only I can print
and and no one else has sophistication
to do something this fancy you know
maybe I used some colors here and I you
know I sign it Sal and I do all sorts of
stuff that makes it really hard to forge
so that no one else can you know no one
else can can put some holograms on it
who knows what I do to it but no one
else can forge it so this is essentially
a piece of paper that I hand you that
says you know what anyone who holds this
piece of paper can go back to the Bank
of Sal and get back a gold piece then
since everyone in the village they trust
that the Bank of Sal will always be
willing to exchange one of these slips
of paper to for gold piece instead of
using a gold piece to buy something why
don't you just use the slip of paper and
even more instead you know for one gold
pieces you know you don't want to
have a stack of one gold piece pieces of
paper around maybe if you gave me five
gold pieces I'll do that in another
color so maybe if you gave me five gold
pieces that that rectangle is much
larger than it should be relative to the
thousand I think you get the point then
I'll do I'll have a liability here that
says five gold pieces banknotes
outstanding like I'll call it B note
outstanding and I'll issue a I think you
have guessed it maybe I'll do in a
different color to show you that these
banknotes can come in different colors
but up once again I'll put a famous
person there maybe and I'll make it
really hard to forge and I'll put
Holograms on it but it'll be denominated
as a five gold piece banknote and now if
you are one of the villagers you gave me
your gold pieces now not only is your
gold safe you have these pieces of paper
that are very hard to forge and that's
that's a key issue there because if they
were easy to forge then someone may be
completely unaffiliated with this
trustworthy bank completely unaffiliated
with Sal could go out and and print
these things so you don't want that to
happen so we're assuming that you can't
Forge this thing and now not only is
your gold safe but you have something
that you can transact with that's
frankly a lot easier than gold I mean I
could even have a denomination that's
you know I could it could be a 500 gold
piece so someone gave me 500 gold pieces
I could give a you know 500 gold piece
banknote out that would be my liability
right because I know that at some point
someone might give me back that 500 gold
piece banknote and I'll have to give
them 500 pieces of gold so that's why
it's a liability and maybe that piece of
currency is orange so it's 500 500 500
thick you get the idea and now this is
super useful now my bank you know we've
we've done all of the other things how
the bank increases the money supply and
fractional lending and how the money
supply just for the total production and
wealth
in economy but now that we found another
useful thing that a bank can do is that
besides securing your gold it's actually
providing a unit of exchange that's
frankly a lot easier to deal with than
gold you can you imagine lugging around
and counting and verifying 500 gold
pieces every time you had to spend it or
you know yeah everyone would have to
have scales etc now people can just
count their weight and as you see this
is money or this is cash and and it you
might be experiencing some form of
dissonance in your head your because
right when I drew that you're like wait
Sal that looks a lot like a dollar bill
and that's true because a dollar bill is
a Federal Reserve Bank Note it is a bank
note from the US Fed there was a time
and this was the time before central
banks and especially if you think about
colonial times you had banks all over
the the I guess the colonies and they
would actually issue their own banknotes
so you didn't have one uniform currency
so one bank note might look like that
and have Bank of Sal another bank note
might have Bank of I don't know a bank
of George Bush or something and and and
people would kind of have to have you
know exchanges between them to realize
which banks are good for what
now we're not as familiar with the term
bank note because we only see one type
or at least one type per country we only
see bank notes from one bank or at least
one bank has the right to issue them
within the United States and that's the
Federal Reserve Bank and it's not backed
by gold it's actually backed by US
Treasuries and I'll go into that a
little later on actually that's a that's
a whole fascinating realm of thought but
I just wanted to get this point home
that all you had that this Bank actually
has this other service of issuing these
banknotes that are different than the
checking deposits which I will cover in
the next video and then I will use both
of those concepts to - I guess redo that
that lending that we did with the
irrigation ditches and the factory to
show you that the gold actually never
never even has to leave the bank the
goal just sits in the bank the whole
time and the bank can just use its bank
notes and cheques to actually conduct
all of the transactions see in the next
video